this one is for the misfits okay the
ones who dare to be different comedian
and magician mary saw chuck has created
a haven for you here at the pass casino
and he's here with the misfit crew yes
all looking very good in your reds and
floral prints i love it now mary just
introduce us to the gang for sure this
is my wife danny
she's gonna be hosting the show okay yes
and this is erica van lee who's one of
the top female magicians in the world
amazing
repping the girl power i know
now now first and foremost before we get
into it just define what is a misfit to
you right misfit i think everybody that
doesn't do the normal right i mean right
just with you know things that just when
people always come to and say when you
get a real job you know i'm thinking
this is the gig right honestly i think
we're all misfits yeah in our own way
everybody's got their own quirky little
thing exactly if you have the
opportunity to be able to share that
quirkiness and be accepted for it yeah
well that's pretty much what the show's
and inspire other people to accept their
own quirks right exactly yeah we're all
part of the misfit family you know right
now you produce the show you also star
in it of course yes just kind of tell us
what to expect yeah well you know i
decided to produce something along with
joe who's the owner of bonkers comedy
club and he said what do you got that
you haven't done yet and i said i've
always wanted to do a misfit show of a
bunch of really cool acts all in one
like a modern day variety show like
vaudeville so we've kind of put this
together and that's our first night
tonight right yeah first night tonight
since you are the host i'll give it to
you what can we expect in the show in
terms of acts because i hear there are
seven what is the audience seven
elements one shows seven acts so we have
everything from magicians
to comedians uh we have uh john shaw who
i like to call the freak show type of
magic acts he does some weird stuff with
um uh popcorn kernels
sucks up his nose puts it out of his
eyeball you'll probably never want to
eat popcorn again but you'll be highly
entertained that's my favorite snack
don't don't ruin popcorn for me
we have a juggler so there's a little
something for everyone okay mixing it
all together and of course magic that is
what you do let's talk about the trick
you're going to show us are you ready
for a trip i don't know i don't know
does it involve popcorn kernels
no popcorn let's do it let's do a card
trick okay okay awesome
all right
let's do it okay so i'm gonna shuffle
through the deck you tell me when to
stop okay okay all right i'm gonna go
ahead and get started here
stop stop stop okay so this will be your
card okay go ahead and take it
you can show everyone just don't show me
well don't look at the monitor okay
okay can you guys see it all right
so i have this pad of paper i'm gonna
try to guess your card okay rocky okay
all right let me see
hold on all right look at me okay okay
what's going through your head right now
okay wait a minute she's reading your
mind
i'm gonna try to guess your card okay
okay
i think i got it
what was your card three of diamonds
can i see
am i allowed to show murray okay okay
okay
you can show everyone
all right
well wouldn't it be incredible if i
actually
got your card right i wouldn't know yeah
yeah it would be amazing all right rocky
watch what is going on she brought out a
lighter
oh
three of diamonds
okay that's your card
wow okay i have so many questions about
the ink about the
it's magic
girl that's what you got in that bag huh
a bag of tricks
thank you wow that's so much fun
what you can expect at the show and
again it's tonight yeah tonight eight
o'clock the past casino and henderson
tickets are still available
bonkerscomedy.com
and uh the nice thing is there's seven
acts and if you don't like one act
there's another one coming right up
it's a great show for everybody everyone
have a great time something for
everybody something for all of us
thank you